اما الفوز او الموت
هكذا عدد المسلمين وتوعد منتخب بلاده فهو
لم يكتفي وقتها بكونه زعيما سياسيا فاشيا
لايطاليا بل نصب نفسه مدربا ومسؤول عن كل
شيء حتى يحصل على كاس العالم
فما قصه هذا التهديد والوعيد
في عام 34 نظمت ايطاليا المونديال واحرزت
اللقب بعدها باربع سنوات نظمت فرنسا
البطوله
لاعبي منتخب بلاده بالحفاظ على الكاس لكن
طلبه كان بصيغه تهديد بالقتل
بدات البطوله وبدا الحشد الصحفي من ابواق
موسليني لتلميع صورته وصورته حسب لدرجه
انه اجبر اللاعبين الطليان على اداء
التحيه الفاشيه في كل مباراه تركما صالح
بلاده وتفرغ للمونديال
اراد ان تكون هذه البطوله رمزا لقوه
الفاشيه وانتصارها وقال للمدرب حينها انت
المسؤول الاول وان فشلت فليكن الرب في
عونك
حياتها هؤلاء اللاعبين كانت في خطر كانوا
يركضون والارض تركض من تحت اقدامهم ليس
هناك اي خيار اما هزه شباك الخصم او توديع
احبتهم للابد ايطاليا تلتقي المجر في
معركه حياه او موت سجل الطليان اربعه
اهداف في حارس مرمى المجر الذي لم تبدو
عليه اي علامات حزن وقتها
لتنطلق الافراح في كل انحاء ايطاليا فقط
سترها هؤلاء اللاعبين تاريخا على العشب
الاخضر وافله من تهديدات موسيني
لاول مره لا اكون حزينا رغم انهم احرزوا
اربعه اهداف في شباكه اشعر بالسعاده فقد
انقذت حياه احد عشر انسانا من الموت
ورغم التشكيك حول روايه التهديد حينها
مصادر عده اكدت ان موسيلين قد هدد بالفعل
مدرب منتخب بلاده انا ذاك فيتوريو بوتسو
في حال خسرت ايطاليا هذا اللقب هذه
البطوله هي اخر بطوله لعبت بنظام خروج
المغلوب المنتخب الايطالي وصل للنهائي
ليلاقي المجر موسيلين قام بارسال برقيه
الى لاعبي ايطاليا تحمل عباره مختصره
الفوز او الموت
روايه اخرى ذكرت ان احد لاعبي المنتخب
الايطالي نفى صحه هذه التهديدات قائلا
انها مجرد اشاعات وان مسيلين حفزهم دون
تهديد وبالرغم من ان الاخيره لم يكن مولعا
بكره القدم الا انه كان يعرف قيمه بطوله
كاس العالم في تجميل صورته ومنحه انجازا
ولوهيا فقد كان يجلس في مدرجات ملاعب
ايطاليا في بطوله عام 34 ويتابع اداء
الحكام ويحلل اداءهم التحكيميه او ربما قد
وصل الامر لتهديدهم ايضا هو كان له ما
تمنى لقد اصبحت طليان اول منتخب في
التاريخ يحقق المونديال
لدورتين متتاليتين
[موسيقى]